Крили нас в основному 120-і, 85-і міни. Танки крили, дуже сильно.
Авіація трохи крила, але не на нашу позицію. По нас, але не на нашу позицію.
А так в основному 120-і.
Я лежав в тому окопчику, скручений, включав секундомір,
то 50 приходів за одну хвилину, це тільки на нашу позицію.
Так Сергій згадує бої на Бахмутському напрямку влітку минулого року.
Там, на нулі, їх обстрілювали від ранку до ночі.
Під час одного зі штурмів на їхню позицію йшли 200 вагнерівців,
а боєкомплект вже закінчувався.
Почався перший бій, другий бій, третій бій.
Їх було дуже багато, а нас було на позиції 12 чоловік.
І тримали, до  останнього тримали.
І, як сказати так правильно,  ми робили все, щоб їх не підпустити.
Підпустили вже тоді, коли зрозуміли, що в нас вже БК немає.
Важко трохи згадувати це все.
Після вагнерівців їхали танки.
А за ними - готувалася йти в наступ ще майже тисяча піхоти.
Тоді військові прийняли ближній бій.
Нас 12 хлопців, побратимів, дали відсіч 200 вагнерівців.
І відступили ми на сусідню позицію,
і нам врятувало життя те, що був високий брусер,
ну, залізна дорога, і просто танки не могли виїхати на нього.
А так, якби танки виїхали, то я б зараз з вами тут не сидів, і не спілкувався б точно.
У нас був ближній бій, і я пам'ятаю, що я стріляв, тоді дивлюся, нема пальця.
Повертаюся до хлопців, до побратима, а в мене лице відкрилося і закрилося.
Через щільні обстріли у Сергія вилетіла кришка від автомата
і зрізала пів обличчя - разом з носом і правим оком.
Коли ми вже трохи відійшли, я побратимів просив,
щоб вони мене застрелили,
бо я розумів, що через мене одного можуть постраждати моїх  п'ять братів.
Він пролежав три години на полі бою, та побратими його врятували - винесли з позицій.
Лікарі давали лише 1% на те, що Сергій виживе.
Два дні в комі був, сім днів у реанімації, більше ніж 100 капельниць за  20 днів, грубо кажучи.
10 операцій було в Мечникова, 11-ту операцію мені в Києві робили, 12-та операція в Івано-Франківську,
потрапив на програму Face to Face.
Вони мені зробили, як сказали, це підготовка до операції,
вживили мені хрящика, а це буде 13-та операція.
Лікарі казали, що будуть ставити мого носика, як то кажуть, оцей ось, що у мене тут є,
він буде перевертатися, накладатися на ніс і буду вже, як то кажуть, красунчик.
А красунчиком його мають зробити американські лицьові хірурги.
Це вже друга операція Сергія у рамках медичної місії Face to Face.
Це кооперація Американської академії лицьової пластичної та реконструктивної хірургії,
фонду Razom for Ukraine і медичної організації INgenius.
Вони безкоштовно роблять складні пластичні операції
та реконструкції обличчя військовим та цивільним,
які внаслідок війни отримали травми голови, обличчя та шиї.
Минулоріч вони прооперували майже 50 військових і цивільних.
Цього року - понад 20 військових.
Цього разу у Львові ми сфокусовані більше на комплексних кейсах по реконструкції обличчя.
Ми беремо кейси, де абсолютно відсутні кістки щелепи.
Тобто нам доводиться робити унікальні операції, де ми пересаджуємо кістки з ноги,
з руки для реконструкції нижньої щелепи, для реконструкції носа.
Тобто ми не тільки візуально допомагаємо пацієнтам повернути обличчя,
ми також допомагаємо їм повернути функцію.
Пацієнти скаржаться на те, що їм важко пережовувати їжу,
наприклад, важко харчуватися, важко дихати.
Мета - не лише допомогти пацієнтам,
але й навчити українських хірургів проводити такі ж складні операції,
щоб у майбутньому вони могли впоратися самостійно,
адже постраждалих від війни в Україні дуже багато.
Найскладнішим є те, що називається мікросудинною реконструкцією,
коли ми беремо частини ноги, щоб реконструювати щелепну кістку.
Крім того, ми робимо дуже складні реконструкції очей,
використовуючи індивідуальні імплантати пацієнта,
щоб замінити частину відсутньої кістки.
Мікросудинні випадки займають 10-12 годин, тобто цілий день.
Це вимагає залучення кількох хірургів, які працюють на голові, на нозі.
Ми працюємо з місцевими лікарями, щоб забезпечити навчання,
щоб вони могли самостійно виконувати складніші операції.
Вони знають багато базових реконструкцій,
тому їм зручно робити лобові клапті та клапті для грудей.
Але у мікросудинній реконструкції та індивідуальних імплантах вони не мають великого досвіду.
І тому я вважаю, що для нас важливо забезпечити навчання,
щоб потім вони могли робити ці процедури самі.
Доктор Абрахам вже проводив такі місії в інших країнах світу.
А коли почув про наслідки війни в Україні - зрозумів, що потрібен тут.
Ми чули про війну та жахливі наслідки, про всіх постраждалих і поранених людей.
І тому ми хотіли допомогти та використати наш досвід,
щоб надавати допомогу пацієнтам, а також навчати лікарів.
Так, у Сполучених Штатах ми робимо це в основному після раку, а також травм, автомобільних аварій тощо.
Але тут, на жаль, це все пов’язане з війною,
тому кульові поранення та осколки, бомби.
Кожна операція - складна і комплексна, а охочих - величезна кількість.
Лише за два тижні хірурги отримали понад 100 заявок.
Та відібрали найскладніші кейси.
Це в основному складні, великі дефекти нижньої щелепи,
дефекти верхньої щелепи, це повна відсутність, наприклад, носа.
Це всі операції, які потребують пересадки кісток з ноги або з руки,
тому що це веде за собою не просто пересадку, а також зшивання судин.
Це дуже специфічні операції, які потребують дуже довгого специфічного тренінгу.
Цей тренінг не входить в частину тренінгу в українській системі поки що,
але це входить в частину тренінгу, наприклад, в Америці.
Григорію мають поставити ще одну пластину для підтримки ока.
У самому пеклі восени під Бахмутом він отримав важке поранення і втратив ліве око.
У нас була в останні два-три дні найскладніша ситуація,
тому що вони нас кожен день, всю добу, це 5, 6, 7, бувало 10 штурмів на нас, на наші позиції.
По мені було пряме влучання, можна так сказати.
Я розумію, що по мені  потрапив ворожий снаряд, осколок.
Це складно назвати вже оком.
Я тоді  щось тримав, схоже на нього,
але я тоді не усвідомив, що це було оком.
Тепер замість ока - протез.
Пластину будуть ставити для того, щоб імплант, який у мене на даний час стоїть,
щоб він стояв на місці, був нерухомий, ні вгору, ні вниз,
щоб через 5 років, 10 років, не було перекосу обличчя.
Такі операції потребують специфічних розхідників і спеціальних матеріалів та устаткування.
Закупити їх допомагають спонсори та фонди, серед яких фонд Razom for Ukraine.
Для нас, українців, і навіть не тільки українців за кордоном,
це дуже важливо, підтримувати Україну в будь-яких сенсах.
Звичайно, медицина  дуже важлива, особливо зараз, коли йде війна.
Але цей проєкт, знову ж таки,  довгостроковий,
і бачити, як наші лікарі ростуть, розвиваються, це дуже круто,
тому що, звичайно, це буде впливати на розвиток самої країни і здоров'я людей.
А для самих військових - це можливість отримати професійну допомогу,
щоб нормально їсти, дихати і мати змогу повернутися до звичного життя.
Я хочу подякувати цій місії.
Вони колосальну роботу  зробили для мене  і для хлопців, я сподіваюся…
Я впевнений, що для хлопців,  для інших також.
Дуже добре, що є такі люди, які допомагають після поранення,
тяжкого поранення,  дуже тяжкого поранення.